welcome back okay before the break we
introduced jenna a special education
teacher community volunteer and soon to
be mom from new jersey and she needed
some help putting together a nursery at
her new home and we were up for the task
so jenna handed over the keys and left
her house in our hands and i worked with
our design team here in new york and our
resident design expert mikhail welch was
boots on the ground in new jersey and we
pulled it on later i think the results
are totally worth it i can't wait for
this reveal take a look
[Music]
all right jenna i think it's time for
you to see what drew and i have come up
with
oh my god
wow oh my goodness how do you feel
amazing oh my god
well let me tell you how it all came
together
drew and i sat down and were like okay
it's baby number one we can't let her
down we went with natural light woods
light grays light blues and we felt like
that was just a simple calming palette
that kind of flows throughout the rest
of the space and we've also incorporated
a little bit of greenery it's always
nice when we can bring the outside
inside right yes all right one of the
things that you're always going to need
in a nursery is the creature right so
our friends over at stoka gave you this
beautiful sleepy and it has like this
whole nest formation where it really
cradles the baby in but best of all just
like all stoker products it grows with
the child and so you can change the
different intervals over time
now when the baby gets up he's ready to
eat well this right here is the trip
trap this slides right up to the dinner
table so the baby can be engaged with
the entire family
so drew and i decided to make an
executive decision okay
we removed the doors on the closet but
let me tell you why okay
the doors kind of would like swing into
each other so that was going to be a
problem so we decided to incorporate
some beautiful curtains we've given you
some fancy designer wallpaper inside of
the closet the other thing that you're
going to need is a lot of storage so we
can give you everything from baskets to
more drawer space incredible our friends
over at stoka gave you two additional
dressers here
now this is probably going to be
something you're going to fall in love
with take a seat in your new chair of
course
you can put your feet up but guess what
this is actually a storage out of it
awesome more storage you know drew that
girl she loves storage i'll tell you
that much
so let's think about it you've had an
exhaustive day all the eighth graders
that you teach they've worn you out you
want to just relax and go to sleep right
yes so behind you we've incorporated
some beautiful blackout shades so you
will be good to go my friend you know
what sit there for one second i got a
little surprise
drew and our friends over at stoker
wanted you to have this beautiful piece
called the x-flori i love it we put it
in our traditional true colors
beautiful so when you're out on the
street everybody will know this is a
fancy drew baby thank you so much this
is amazing i kind of want to come back
out to jersey and visit you you can this
is unbelievable i didn't really have a
vision and this just
blows my mind oh
thank you so much pikel thank you so
much drew this is everything we ever
wanted
thank you jenna for letting us be a part
of creating something so filled with
love it's true we wanted your chair in
the power position you can see the entry
you can see the whole room the crib the
changing tables it's just the right sort
of feng shui place to put it and i did
have to take your closet doors off
because they went right up to the
front door of the room and i felt like
you were going to live in like a laverne
and shirley situation every day of your
life so this way your storage is open
you can close the curtains when you need
privacy for it
because it's just been that kind of day
or you can display it open
and we just went with really neutrals
really soft tones i've learned that when
you have a new baby you really make that
room for you and as your toddler grows
up it becomes their room and it never
looks like a catalog it's always this
amazing amalgamation and collection of
the things that you get over the years
and it all changes but if that room when
you're first having your baby is more
for you
that's actually a standard in the
industry and so this is all for you and
your journey and i just want to thank
stoka for making all of this possible
they are best in class
and it is an honor to be able to do this
project for jenna with them and your
products truly make parents and children
more confident as they grow older and
together and i'm always looking to take
care of people in need of a little home
refresh or the beginning of the greatest
journey of your life so please go to the
drewberrymoreshow.com share your story i
might design for you if you'll have me
we'll be right back
[Music]